if you're just starting the business
make sure it's around something that you
love doing you're intensely passionate
about and you feel there's something
that's missing in the marketplace right
now that you can provide otherwise if
you're just doing an average product
selling to average customers you're
gonna have average or less or worse
results you have to be able to pour
yourself into your business hi I'm Evan
Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and same answering a
question from a reader Samara who wrote
in to say I don't have big ideas I'm
looking to start my own company nothing
big maybe start by making my own makeup
for students or something doesn't take
experience an original idea but I
haven't decided yet
do you have any thoughts so Samara first
year I think why do you want to be an
entrepreneur okay if you want to be an
entrepreneur just for the experience or
you know just for something fun or think
you're gonna make a lot of money then
you're probably not gonna have a lot of
success you want to be an entrepreneur
because you want to be an entrepreneur
you want to be a business owner and you
want to have an impact if you want a
winning business idea it has to be
around something that you love doing and
something that you feel is missing
it could be makeup I'm not saying
makeups a bad idea makeup could be great
there's tons of entrepreneurs we've had
a lot of success in makeup what is
missing in makeup right now if you're
gonna sell the students in makeup what
do they need what do they need that's
not out there right now and how can you
provide that service you have to love
makeup do you use makeup yourself do you
feel better using makeup you have a
personal story and attachment to makeup
that people can resonate with that you
can share that by telling your story
people are gonna want to work with you
you have to love makeup and then again
you have to find a way that people will
want to use what you have there's
something missing if you're gonna start
a new product or service there has to be
something missing right now that's not
there when I started my website having
comical calm I started her in around
having the famous entrepreneur profiles
and stories I felt like these famous
entrepreneurs really helped me their
stories inspired me motivated me and
there wasn't enough information online
out there so I went out and created the
largest resource for
entrepreneur stories and advice anywhere
online and people they've resonated with
them and they came to the website and
they started for the newsletter and they
bought products you have to be able to
find something that means something to
you that's important and that nobody
else is doing you can fill that void
I know it's hard thinking of a business
idea and too many entrepreneurs just
jump on the first idea that comes to
them but that's a recipe for failure and
you may end up spending tons of money
and not being able to recoup it and get
it back so you're really need to think
are you meant to be an entrepreneur like
is this something that is a burning
thing that you have to do like if you
don't try this out now you're gonna
regret it for the rest of your life or
is it something like yeah we'll try it
see what happens like if that's your
attitude it's not gonna work
don't do it go get a job do something
else but don't start your own business
you have to feel it and for those of you
who are in business you know what I'm
talking about because it's hard it's
rough it sucks
there's a lot of crap that's thrown at
you you have to feel it you have to want
it to keep going every day and then
again make sure that whatever you're
providing is unique stands out there's a
need you use it you love it and other
people can benefit from it as well good
luck for those of you watching if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below and makes gonna do more for you
and I want to hear what you have to
think what do you think about this video
let me know leave it in the comments
below and if you have a question for
your company I'd love to try to answer
it for you in the comment section thank
you guys it means a lot to me and I'll
see you in the next episode